the cdc is coming out with a positive
prediction on the pandemic projecting
fewer cases and deaths in the coming
weeks
the agency says weekly deaths could fall
to 3200
by april 10th dr marty mccary is a fox
news contributor and professor of health
policy and management
at johns hopkins school of public policy
um so you
i'm sorry public health uh was it about
a month ago that you wrote a wall street
journal op-ed and you got a whole bunch
of criticism
do you feel a little vindication this
morning
well look i'm not looking to win an
argument i don't think those people are
going to apologize when the numbers show
that the model was correct and it seems
like you can only have models that
predict
things far worse than reality if you
predict predict an accurate model
some people say look the projection i
said gave people a false sense of
security
i think it actually encouraged people to
do what they
they need to do until we get to that
point because hope is on the way and i
think the numbers are pointing that way
okay so what are we what are we seeing
in these numbers here let's see the call
for
the case is dropping this is the seven
day moving average uh from january 20
january 21 was 250 000 in march down to
50 000. you think this has some to do
with
herd immunity and vaccines can you
explain
yeah first of all herd immunity is
significant slowing when fewer people
are susceptible out there it's not a
hard cut off and in fact it's been
kicking in
we already have herd immunity dana for
the nation's 23 million health care
workers most have been
vaccinated and some others who haven't
already have natural immunity from prior
infection
we're about a week or two away from herd
immunity in america's nursing homes
cases they are down 98 percent 10 states
have had days
with zero deaths now what do you call
that when a place has zero deaths in a
day
i call that herd immunity we're going to
see more herd immunity
across the country in april and into may
and that's you know that's
part of the difference in vaccination
rates but we're seeing some really good
news and i don't think we're going to
extinguish this virus as i wrote
in that piece we're going to see cases
linger but a debate's going to ensue
who are those people and those are going
to be primarily young people
who have asymptomatic and mild disease
they could linger through may and even
early june
and what do you think the next is that
the next big argument or what do you
think that next big argument is
yeah and there was an article in the new
york times this morning that
conservatives tend to understate the
risks and
democrats exaggerate the risks and they
did a survey showing that
uh democrats believe that about 20
percent of covid patients are
hospitalized not true it's about one
percent
and so what you're going to see is this
argument when there's cases in may
where some who want the pandemic to keep
going are going to say
that's a significant public health risk
and it could surge again
but the truth is those are young
asymptomatic cases
and they're not going to surge because
there are fewer susceptible people out
there there's a lot of vaccinated
and natural immunity from prior and
actually you still recommend that people
delay their second dose
that's right we could save more lives if
people delay the second dose the uk is
doing it
get the second dose at 12 weeks that's
what i recommend all right
dr martin mccarry always pleasure to
have you